[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 2017 se celebran los 150 años de la
existencia de canadá
sí
[Música]
el día concreto del cumpleaños fue el
pasado 1 de julio y con este vídeo entre
otras cosas desde visual polític
queremos decirles a todos los
canadienses felicidades
y es que amigos motivos no faltan el
país de la policía montada llega a su
150 aniversario en plena forma porque si
algo podemos decir es que canadá es hoy
un país que está de moda
y si canadá es la tierra natal de muchas
estrellas que todos conocemos
[Música]
pero en los últimos años ha sido
especialmente una quien ha puesto al
país en el candelero de la política
internacional nos referimos como no a
justin no a ese justin no a justin crudo
su primer ministro
en serio amigos canadá cumple su 150
aniversario siendo uno de los países más
ricos con más calidad de vida y más
admirados de todo el mundo no está nada
mal verdad pues bien la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es cuál es la causa de
todo esto cuáles son las principales
características con las que canadá
celebra este simbólico aniversario vamos
a verlo en este vídeo pero lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es ponernos en
situación
la gran transformación puede que no
escuchéis hablar mucho de canadá pero
podemos decir que este país no es
cualquier cosa de hecho es el segundo
país más grande de todo el mundo su
territorio ojo abarca seis zonas
horarias si menudo lío tiene que ser y
además cuál pensáis que es el país con
más kilómetros de costa de todo el
planeta si así es canadá claro que como
bien sabéis todos los suscriptores de
visual político ni la superficie ni los
kilómetros de costa hacen que los
ciudadanos de un país sean más o menos
ricos tengan más o menos oportunidades o
disfruten de más o menos bienestar
así que veamos siendo así que se esconde
realmente detrás del éxito de canadá
pues en todo esto tiene mucho que ver
los pésimos años que el país vivió entre
finales de los 80 y principios de los 90
y durante esos años canadá sufrió
estancamiento si crisis hasta el punto
de que en 1995 el mismísimo walt street
journal
llegó a calificar a canadá como un
miembro honorario del tercer mundo por
su incapacidad para controlar las
cuentas públicas desde entonces como
podéis ver las cosas han cambiado mucho
muchísimo podríamos decir que canadá
supo conservar sus puntos fuertes y
despojarse de todo aquello que le estaba
causando tantos problemas y sobre todo
amigos por encima de todas las cosas
los canadienses comprendieron lo
importante que resultan estas dos
palabras competitividad e integración
tras estos años tan malos de los 80 y
los 90 los canadienses se dieron cuenta
de varias cosas por un lado que antes de
pensar en gastar hay que pensar en crear
y que para eso hace falta inversión
empresas y comercio mucho comercio
dicho y hecho hoy canadá es la séptima
economía más libre del planeta pero ojo
si hablamos de libertad no tenemos que
quedarnos tan solo en la parte económica
el instituto fraser publica un estudio
el índice de libertad humana que mide
tanto las libertades económicas como las
libertades civiles es decir mide lo que
las personas podemos hacer y no hacer
pues bien según este estudio canadá es
el sexto país más libre de todo el
planeta para que os hagáis una idea
españa se sitúa un poquito bueno
bastante más abajo en el puesto 36
también por ejemplo perú en el 53 o
argentina en el 103
al final amigos lo sabemos todos la
capacidad de las personas para crear y
prosperar es asombrosa eso sí cuando no
se ven sometidas a gobiernos corruptos y
a todo tipo de ingenierías sociales
porque no canadá no es un paraíso fiscal
ni nadie se queda tirado en la calle
[Música]
y para quienes lo estéis pensando la
minería es para este país mucho menos
importante que para perú o chile de
hecho con el hundimiento del precio de
las materias primas y del petróleo de
2014 la economía canadiense apenas se ha
resentido
[Música]
tal vez una explicación está en la
fuerte descentralización que tiene el
país
canadá está dividido en 10 provincias y
3 territorios que tienen tantas
competencias que incluso en 2017
tuvieron que firmar un tratado de libre
comercio entre ellas tal como lo
escucháis el nuevo acuerdo de comercio
interprovincial espera inyectar miles de
millones a la economía la
descentralización aquí es enorme y eso
tradicionalmente ha supuesto muchos
costes para las empresas que por así
decir no operaban en un mercado único
sino en muchos diferentes con
regulaciones distintas en ontario la
gasolina debe tener por lo menos un 5%
de etanol manitoba insiste en una mezcla
del 85 por ciento la parte buena es que
todo esto ha funcionado como contrapeso
al gobierno federal y también que ha
permitido alentar la competencia entre
provincias algo que claro favorece las
buenas políticas públicas de todas
formas amigos con este nuevo acuerdo
bueno el objetivo es superar estas como
decirlo sorprendentes barreras y luego
como vimos aquí también en visual
político está la apuesta canadiense por
el mundo
culturalismo y es que la verdad sea
dicha hoy por hoy este país es uno de
los mejores ejemplos de integración de
todo el mundo
[Música]
y para ti
el mosaico canadiense
pero en qué consiste todo esto del
multiculturalismo canadiense pues
básicamente en aceptar que la diversidad
cultural no es una amenaza sino un
patrimonio y una fuente de oportunidades
esto sí claro siempre subordinada a una
serie de valores como la democracia el
imperio de la ley o la igualdad de las
personas
[Música]
es decir para ser canadiense y ser
bienvenido a este país no tienes que
sustituir tu cultura por ninguna otra
sino que tienes que aceptar y
comprometerte con todos esos valores que
si de algo hablan es de libertad
fijaos canadá es uno de los países con
más población inmigrante del mundo uno
de cada cinco canadienses no ha nacido
en canadá y este porcentaje en ciudades
como toronto se acerca o supera el 50% y
todo apunta a que en el futuro serán aún
más porque cada año ingresan al país más
de 300.000 nuevos inmigrantes una de las
tasas más altas del mundo
[Música]
y sabéis que no hay problemas si lo
dijimos la inmigración aquí no es libre
sigue un sistema basado en tres pilares
puntos reagrupación familiar y
refugiados de estos pilares el más
importante es el sistema de puntos que
para conceder los permisos de residencia
y trabajo valora cosas como tener una
oferta de trabajo lo más importante
obtener una titulación o saber inglés
por ejemplo queréis saber cuál es el
resultado pues atentos
ocho de cada diez canadienses consideran
que la inmigración es buena para la
economía lo que claro no es extraño
porque todas las estadísticas muestran
que los inmigrantes los nuevos
canadienses tienen más estudios trabajan
más generan más negocios e incluso
consumen menos dólares de los programas
sociales hay normas sí pero también una
cultura de integración y acogida como
pocas de hecho desde 1977 todos los
ciudadanos de canadá pueden tener otra
nacionalidad sin restricción así que
cuando una persona emigra a este país y
al cabo de los años obtiene su
nacionalidad no tiene que renunciar a la
de su país de origen
ahora bien puede que si algo refleja a
la perfección el espíritu de este nuevo
canadá sea su primer ministro
justin crudo air one bus rock del mundo
ancho
[Música]
justin crudo una estrella de la política
ya sin crudo llegó al gobierno en 2015
prácticamente por sorpresa y con tan
solo 44 años pues bien hoy es uno de los
políticos más populares de todo el mundo
y en canadá desde luego no es diferente
esto es algo que las encuestas nos
muestran claramente por ejemplo una
reciente encuesta de ábacos data sobre
el liderazgo del primer ministro muestra
que el 70 por ciento de los canadienses
confían en que trudeau gestione bien la
relación con los aliados el 73% confía
en su responsabilidad a la hora de tomar
decisiones y el 62 confía en que sus
decisiones serán buenas
ya les gustaría a muchos políticos tener
estos índices de aprobación me ha dolido
mucho y me tengo que fastidio ahora bien
la verdad sea dicha
'justin trudeau no es un político al uso
para nada el primer ministro de canadá
ha puesto sobre la mesa un programa y
una forma de gobierno bastante
diferentes a lo que suele ser la norma
habitual un mero vistazo a su gabinete
es toda una muestra de sus intenciones y
también de la realidad de canadá
box
de los 30 ministros 15 son mujeres
encontramos a un ex combatiente en
bosnia y en afganistán a una antigua
voluntaria en níger es directivos de
empresas o incluso a varios ministros
six una religión originaria del estado
de punjab en la india
la última incorporación por cierto ha
sido ahmed husein un refugiado somalí
que llegó a canadá como refugiado con 16
años y que hoy ostenta el cargo de
ministro de inmigración
pues bien sus prioridades políticas son
tan poco habituales como su gabinete por
un lado una de las apuestas claves del
gobierno canadiense es impulsar el
comercio entre los pueblos atentos a las
palabras de su ministra de asuntos
exteriores las crecientes barreras
comerciales perjudican a las personas a
las que están destinadas a ayudar frenan
el crecimiento sofocan la innovación y
matan el empleo esta es una lección que
debemos aprender de la historia más
claro agua por eso trudeau quiere firmar
incluso un acuerdo de libre comercio con
china luego a diferencia de otros
gobiernos el de true don't know sólo
rechaza el proteccionismo sino que
quiere impulsar el cambio productivo de
la mano de la inteligencia artificial y
la automatización nada de poner trabas a
la tecnología que si algo ha demostrado
a lo largo de la historia es que mejora
la vida de las personas y también genera
empleos más valiosos
esto parece fácil verdad pero no es nada
común de plantear y defender al fin y al
cabo los incentivos de los gobiernos
suelen ir por otro lado la otra gran
prioridad y tal vez el valor clave del
gobierno de todo eso apuesta por
impulsar los derechos civiles y
convertir a canadá en como decirlo en un
verdadero referente internacional fijaos
por ejemplo en la fuerza de esta imagen
true 2 ha convertido en el primer primer
ministro en encabezar una marcha del
orgullo lgtb y también el último
programa anunciado recientemente en
junio de 2017 el que podemos denominar
como política de asistencia
internacional feminista
así es el gobierno de crudo no ha tenido
reparos en reivindicarse como feminista
y entre otras cosas ha decidido que la
inmensa mayor parte del presupuesto de
cooperación se dirija a favorecer el
empoderamiento y los derechos de la
mujer allí donde no son respetados
es un símbolo pero a veces los símbolos
son importantes no os parece símbolos y
gestos como su postura hacia los
refugiados de siria atentos a las
palabras de este peculiar primer
ministro en richmond quien se va a
vender hearts and the family and win
conflicto en soria en formentera
aguanta los reproches por welcome nores
verdens para sneijder se enfrenta a las
generales
pues bien a día de hoy han llegado a
canadá más de 40.000 refugiados sirios
casi la mitad por cierto mediante
patrocinios es decir bajo el respaldo de
ciudadanos que se comprometen a
responsabilizarse del bienestar de estas
personas eso sí es solidaridad y ojo
porque como lo cortés no quita lo
valiente nada de buenismo el gobierno
canadiense ha anunciado su intención de
incrementar el gasto militar más de un
70 por ciento de aquí a 2024 para hacer
del ejército canadiense una fuerza ágil
y moderna
[Música]
comercio puertas abiertas a la
tecnología integración derechos civiles
seguridad a mí desde luego no me suena
nada mal sobre todo cuando tenemos en
cuenta que este gobierno parece tener
muy claro que antes de hablar de gasto
hay que hablar de creación de riqueza
bueno amigos así es como canadá ha
llegado a su 150 aniversario todo muy
bonito verdad pues esperad un momento
porque también hay sombras pero de esta
especie del lado oscuro o amenazas que
se ciernen sobre este gigantesco país os
hablaremos en uno de nuestros siguientes
vídeos no penséis que solo nos vamos a
quedar con el lado bonito para no
perderte lo claro no olvides suscribirte
a visual polític por cierto turno para
ti qué opinión te merece justin crudo
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y también en esta encuesta si te ha
gustado el vídeo no olvides darle al
like un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]